hi this is sour patch kids ice cream
which means that they put sour patch
kids in an ice cream or they made ice
cream with sour patch kids which is a
different idea than cereal but don't pay
attention to that right now
it's it's not important what is
important is this this is my tactical
shovel
I bought this off of Amazon the same
place I got that material from weird
website you can buy all these things and
it seems to know exactly what you want
whenever you don't even think that you
want it so anyway this is a tactical
shovel and if you don't know what a
tactical shovel is buckle up because I'm
about to learn you all about tactical
shovels this is a work of art you think
about art now shut up about that think
about shovels man has been using shovels
to do pretty much anything since the
dawn of time and this is my baby
this is what should I name my shovel
hey this is Becky and Becky is a
tremendous tool with a million uses now
I will get back to the ice cream real
quick don't think that this is a video
tricking you
it ain't no clickbait this is important
to this because I bought this because it
has a million in one uses you know what
a million in one uses means that means
it can do about sixteen different things
so it's a shovel thud it's a shovel it
can shovel things as in shovel ice cream
into my mouth
it can also this is a harpoon now when I
say a tactical shovel I'm then tactical
shovel you can use it for tactics like
fishing or hunting or pruning in general
and when you take it into harpoon mode
it's still a shovel it's still got the
shovel part of it it's so cool and this
isn't even just a show it's also a blade
because it's sharp and it's sharp here
too so it's an axe so you can dig as you
chop and then cut when you're done
digging and then you can cut out the
heart and then you spleen and then you
can slice it upon your breathing's after
you're done hunting
I'm not going to discriminate on what
you're gonna be hunting with this I said
it had a million in one uses I came up
with a million you know magic with your
brain that you are on the Serengeti
plains the plains of Serengeti seringai
and you're in the woods of Serengeti and
you were being stalked by something
flunking its way through the brush
you can hear it behind you you can hear
it around every corner
oh it thinks that you're its prey
no you will out right from your crack
your tactical shovel and yes it can do
anything so not only are you being
stalked by this but it's getting cold
the nightmares blowing across your nips
and you need fire so what do you do I'm
not gonna talk to you you [ __ ] you
settle it for the night because the
whistle blasts obviously terrified the
creature but then you pull out this
[Music]
serve and you pull out your knife
because it's dark it's night it's cold
you need it you need you need fire this
is not a toy I am a professional I knew
exactly what I'm doing
Oh God I know exactly what I'm doing
look at me when I'm talking please okay
so you've got your knife you've got your
fire you're no longer cold and it's no
longer night because you've got light on
the fire so now the creature makes its
move but you've already chopped down the
entire nearby forest creating traps of
various sizes and utility around your
camp you've put torches around a hundred
square meter perimeter around your base
nothing can approach without you knowing
about it because you've also set trip
wires from strands vines that you've cut
and sliced with the knife edge and the
axe edge and then you've dug a poo hole
for which you can poop in without having
to go into the woods and worry about
being ambushed with your pants down
it is the utility shop it is incredible
and I don't need to justify why I bought
this to anybody I am making this
declaration that this is a useful tool
to survive in all those survival
situations that I find my
self in everyday and it is not a waste
of money it is very useful and the
million and one use of it is to try ice
cream this is the sour patch kids ice
cream review now as I have said before
light light Amy did you know this is a
light ice cream no it's not declare it
says light and okay so off to a bad
start a lot of things start off bad and
then they get worse but I'm gonna give
it the benefit of the doubt and say this
is starting off bad but could get better
because I like frozen yogurt this is
neither of those things so that point
doesn't really make any sense here but I
like that so maybe I'll like this ice
cream with candy in it is not my
favorite thing but it's combination that
is tried and true and I like sour things
sour things are my favourite candy I
said that it was my favorite candy in
the last video and therefore I can't be
lying about it in this video my ice
cream was completely melted by them but
that's fun because I'm really looking
for the flavor profile that tastes the
texture is it all gonna work together
and is it all going to be a great taste
sensation that's gonna sweep the nation
ah their fears so this is an
aesthetically pleasing ice cream I like
the look of this it looks good it looks
inviting
it looks colorful and maybe you'd like
this it's kind of got a primary thing
going on yeah it's good okay zoom out so
I give the look of it to enthusiastic
thumbs up but all ice cream comes down
to the taste and what's curious here is
if the chewiness that is Sour Patch Kids
is going to get in the way of chewiness
of the ice cream it's gonna be like this
gumminess inside of it which I don't
typically like so
it is gumming but it's not bad that is
quite good that's really good
that's shockingly good maybe should I
clean my shovel all right all right
thank you're funny
what's amazing about this is it is a
light ice cream and it's mixed with
sorbet and it's got the chewy chunks of
sour patch kids but it's very good it's
it's like really good and what's even
more fascinating is I can taste the sour
the sour is totally coming through
whereas in the cereal
it did have a sour taste to it but this
the sour is like enhancing the
experience and I think it was a smart
move going to sorbet and even light ice
cream it's kind of like trying to make
it not seem absurdly unhealthy which I
get but it's candy and ice cream it's
not gonna be healthy I always say that
ice cream shouldn't try to be healthy
because it's not it never will be
it is a treat to be enjoyed occasionally
and sparingly
and therefore it shouldn't try to be
something that it's not chalo top is
fine but at the end of the day I would
just rather have real ice cream but this
is great this is really good it's a
hundred and eighty calories per serving
a serving is two thirds of a cup usually
a serving is like half a cup of ice
cream which nobody would ever eat
there's nine of these in this container
which means that this container contains
1620 calories in total which is not bad
if I ate all of this I wouldn't even get
my daily required amount of calories
because I'm a big boy and I need my
calories it's really good and I love
this hour to it it's got a bit of a tang
Oh what I didn't finish my idea sorbet
has a bit of tartness to it which is not
too far from being a sour you go too far
on the tartness you get sour and this
enhances that but not in the back way
it's really good because out my fear was
that sour with milk based ice cream in
its entirety would taste just like the
milk in the cereal but this does it's
got this great sweetness to it it's
almost too sweet but I'm not a chopped
judge I don't care if something's too
sweet does there it's supposed to be in
it with how sweet it is like I don't get
how some judge can bite into a sugar
bomb of a dessert and be like please too
sweet
Oh whatever it's fine there is literally
creme brulee which is burnt sugar and
you can't say that's too sweet like I
don't get how you get more sweet than
this this is great it's a very sweet
it's very tart the sour comes through I
would eat this regularly because it's
great Amy it's really good and it's got
like this marbling to it I think I think
these red are like rivers of blood or
rivers of like the sourness that runs
through it because I don't see any red
bits so that's really where the TARDIS
comes from but it's really aesthetically
pleasing to the eye it's not too many
calories I mean it's a lot of sugar but
you know it's not gonna be healthy if
you're getting something ice cream based
it's not gonna be good for you however
this is not my favorite ice cream I will
say that it's very good but it is
specific case I I wouldn't say that you
know you can bite into an ice cream and
be like Oh too sweet but you wouldn't
want it all the time to be that sweet
you want sweetness on occasion you want
to target us on occasion you want to
know what the best ice cream is one of
the greatest ice creams in the world is
made right in my
town of Cincinnati graters black
raspberry chocolate chip now you
wouldn't think that would be a great
combination on its service but it is if
you if you haven't had this it is
phenomenal it's a great ice cream in the
black raspberry just works super well
and the chocolate chips which I'm not
typically a fan of chocolate chips in
ice creams in general because usually
they get too tough and they they have
this crunch to it that's unpleasant I'd
rather have chocolate just melt in my
mouth but the chocolate in this ice
cream is great its soft its chewy for
some reason even if it's frozen solid it
is a fantastic ice cream my favorite ice
cream bar none is butter pecan but that
changes in quality depending on which
brand you get it from graters black
raspberry chip is the only one to get
this flavor and you can get it anywhere
you can even get it in California you
can get it wherever Kroger's has its
grubby mitts in there's nothing wrong
with Kroger's that I know of and you can
always say that about corporations
because you never know what's shaping an
updo makes are bad kids
actually oh no that's just the ice cream
Nestle is job in conclusion the sour
patch kids ice cream is great it is
delicious it would not be my go-to
dessert but it is way up there if I saw
this available wherever I happen to be
and ice cream was raining down in the
sky and all I had was my shovel my fire
my boat my fence my traps and my show an
ice cream was there in various different
flavors but sour patch kids ice cream
was raining down among them I might
so in that hypothetical scenario pretty
good so anyways thank you everybody so
much for watching I know you all asked
for this none of you asked for this but
it happened anyway life may throw you a
curveball sometimes so you would have to
just roll with the punches and the only
way you're gonna be able to roll with
the punches is if you get yourself a
tactical shovel hit that Bell to be
notified of whenever I'm up to some
shady [ __ ] and maybe subscribe I don't
know if those are mutually exclusive I
guess you have to do both which is an
odd system when you really think about
can you ring the bell without being
subscribed Amy can you ring the bell
without being subscribed no no I don't
want to find out yet you just find out
cuz I have no idea anyway try that but
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you haven't seen me eat the cereal
yet don't waste your life but I'll put
the link in the description anyway so
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video